will Aunt Becky really go from fuller
house to the big house I mean it's hard
to imagine Lori Loughlin locked up it's
something isn't it even for one day let
alone forty years but things just got
worse for Lachlan in the college bribery
scandal I think given the seriousness of
the crime it's very likely that Lori
Lachlan will serve prison time
Lori Lachlan was grilled by the
paparazzi this morning at a West
Hollywood car wash you'll be doing the
same a few hours later prosecutors
announced they added a conspiracy to
commit money laundering charge to her
indictment the actress and her husband
are accused of paying a half a million
dollar bribe in the College Admission
scandal yesterday Felicity Huffman who
paid fifteen thousand announced she's
pleading guilty why Lori's decision
might be taking longer as there could
still be negotiations going on and again
this is a much bigger decision for her
team to make whether she's gonna take
the plea deal which could involve years
not months
in fact Lori now faces a potential
maximum penalty of 40 years federal
prosecutors are recommending that
Felicity sentence include incarceration
at the low end of the sentencing
guidelines
ultimately this is up to a judge to
decide however if it's on the lower end
you know it could be a couple of weeks
to up to four months potentially that
she's spent behind bars hi William how's
felicity doing thanks for asking
Felicity's husband actor William H Macy
who was not charged was asked about the
case yesterday how she holding on and if
the actresses do face prison time based
on these charges and the fact that they
have not been in legal trouble before
and that they probably aren't a security
risk they'll probably be at a minimum
security prison very similar to the one
that Martha Stewart spent time at now
Felicity's plea hearing has been set for
May 24th in Boston and how about this
Netflix has canceled the scheduled
release of Felicity's romantic comedy
other hood it was supposed to start
streaming on the 26th
[Music]
[Applause]